de cette démocratie,
et ce n'est pas une erreur toutes les 360 milliards de fois que notre démocratie
essaie de prendre une décision.
C'est à chaque fois,
sur chaque question importante.
Nous devons mettre fin à cette société politique bovine.
Il s'avère que nous devons adopter
une attitude myrmicéenne --
c'est comme ça qu'Internet l'écrit --
l'attitude appréciative des fourmis
qui nous permette de reconnaître ce défaut,
de sauver notre espèce et nos semblables.
Si vous connaissez Aaron Swartz,
vous savez que nous l'avons perdu
il y a tout juste un an.
C'était à peu près 6 semaines
avant ma conférence TED,
et j'étais si reconnaissant envers Chris
pour m'avoir demandé de venir,
non pas pour la chance de venir vous parler,
même si c'était super,
mais parce que ça m'a sorti d'une grande dépression.
Je ne pouvais pas commencer à décrire la tristesse.
Car je devais me concentrer.
Je devais me concentrer sur ce que j'allais vous dire.
Ça m'a sauvé.
Mais après l'excitation, l'enthousiasme,
et la puissance qui viennent de cette communauté,
j'ai commencé à aspirer à une façon moins stérile,
moins académique, d'adresser ces problèmes,
ceux dont je parlais.
Nous avons choisi le New Hampshire
comme cible pour ce mouvement politique,
parce que les primaires dans le New Hampshire
sont vraiment cruciales.
C'était un groupe appelé le New Hampshire Rebellion
qui a commencé à parler de la façon de rendre
cette question de corruption centrale en 2016.
Mais c'est une autre âme qui a capté mon imagination,
une femme du nom de Doris Haddock, aussi appelée Granny D.
Le 1er janvier 1999, il y a 15 ans,
à l'âge de 88 ans, Granny D a débuté une marche.
Elle a commencé à Los Angeles,
et elle a marché jusqu'à Washington D.C.
avec une unique pancarte sur sa poitrine disant :
« réforme du financement des campagnes politiques »
18 mois plus tard,
à l'âge de 90 ans,
elle est arrivée à Washington, suivie par des centaines de gens,
y compris des membres du Congrès
qui étaient arrivés en voiture un mile avant l'arrivée
pour marcher à ses côtés.
(Rires)
Je ne dispose pas de 13 mois
pour traverser le pays.
J'ai trois enfants qui détestent marcher
et une femme qui apparemment
déteste encore quand je m'absente,
étonnamment,
donc ce n'était pas possible,
mais je me suis demandé
si l'on pouvait un peu s'inspirer de Granny D.
Pourquoi pas une marche, non pas de 5 000 km,
mais de 300 km à travers le New Hampshire,
en janvier ?
Ainsi, le 11 janvier,
le jour anniversaire de la mort d'Aaron,
nous avons entamé une marche qui a pris fin le 24 janvier,
le jour de naissance de Granny D.
200 personnes nous ont rejoints lors de cette marche,
tandis que nous parcourions le New Hampshire de haut en bas,
en discutant de ce problème.
Ce qui m'a étonné,
et ce à quoi je ne m'attendais pas,
c'était de trouver la passion et la colère
qui était partagée par tous ceux avec qui nous avons parlés pendant cette marche.
Nous avions trouvé dans un sondage que 96% des Américains
pensaient qu'il était important
de réduire l'influence de l'argent en politique.
Les politiciens et les experts
disent qu'il n'y a rien à faire,
que les Américains ne s'en préoccupent pas,
mais c'est parce que 91% des Américains
pensent qu'il n'y a rien à faire à ce sujet.
C'est cet écart entre les 96% et les 91%
qui explique notre politique de résignation.
Après tout, au moins 96% d'entre nous
aimerait pouvoir voler comme Superman,
mais à cause des 91% d'entre nous au moins qui n'y croient pas,
on ne saute pas du haut d'un immeuble à chaque fois
qu'on en ressent le besoin.
C'est parce que nous acceptons nos limites
et il en va de même avec cette réforme.
Mais lorsque vous donnez aux gens ce sentiment d'espoir,
vous commencez à faire fondre ce sentiment absolu d'impossibilité.
Comme le disait Harvey Milk, si vous leur donnez l'espoir,
vous leur donner une chance, une façon de penser
que ces changements sont possibles.
De l'espoir.
L'espoir est la seule chose que nous, les amis d'Aaron,
avons échoué à lui donner,
parce que nous lui avons laissé perdre ce sentiment d'espoir.
J'aime ce garçon comme j'aime mon fils.
Mais nous l'avons laissé tomber.
J'aime mon pays,
et je ne vais pas le laisser tomber.
Je ne vais pas le laisser tomber.
Nous allons maintenir ce sentiment d'espoir,
et nous allons lutter pour ça,
aussi impossible que la bataille puisse paraître.
Que se passe-t-il ensuite ?
Nous avons commencé cette marche avec 200 personnes,
l'an prochain, ils seront 1000
sur différentes routes,
à marcher au mois de janvier
et convergeront jusqu'à Concord pour célébrer cette cause,
puis en 2016, avant les primaires,
ils seront 10 000 à traverser l'état,
pour se rassembler à Concord et célébrer cette cause.
Après notre marche, les gens dans le pays ont commencé à demander :
« Pouvons-nous faire de même dans notre état ? »
Nous avons créé une plateforme nommée G.D. Walkers,
c'est-à-dire les marcheurs de Granny D,
et les marcheurs de Granny D dans le pays
vont défiler pour cette réforme. Numéro 1.
Numéro 2 : lors de cette marche,
l'un des fondateurs de Thunderclap, David Cascino,
était avec nous et a demandé :
« Que pouvons-nous faire ? »
Ils ont donc développé une plateforme,
que nous annonçons aujourd'hui,
qui nous permet de rassembler les électeurs
qui sont engagés dans cette idée de réforme.
De n'importe quel endroit,
au New Hampshire ou ailleurs,
vous pouvez vous inscrire et être informés
où les candidats se situent sur cette question
afin de décider pour qui voter
en fonction de qui va rendre cette possibilité réelle.
Enfin, numéro 3, le plus difficile.
Nous sommes à l'ère des comités d'action politique ("Super PAC")
Hier, Merriam a annoncé
que Merriam-Webster inclurait officiellement "Super PAC"
comme nom commun dans le dictionnaire.
Le 1er mai, c'est-à-dire "May Day",
nous allons faire une expérience.
Nous allons essayer de lancer
ce qui pourrait être un Super PAC
pour mettre fin à tous les comités d'action politique.
Voilà comment ça devrait marcher.
Depuis un an, nous travaillons avec des analystes et des experts politiques
pour calculer combien coûterait de rassembler suffisamment de voix
pour une victoire au Congrès
afin de rendre cette réforme possible.
Un demi million ? Un milliard ?
Combien ?
Quel que soit ce chiffre,
nous allons lancer une campagne
de financement participatif,
comme Kickstarter mais pour la politique,
d'abord une campagne du bas vers le haut,
où les gens s'engageront à donner quelques dollars
qui dépendent de la réalisation d'objectifs ambitieux,
et lorsque ces objectifs seront atteints,
nous nous tournerons vers les plus gros investisseurs
afin qu'ils contribuent à rendre possible, pour nous,
le genre de comité d'action politique nécessaire pour gagner,
pour changer la façon dont l'argent influe sur la politique,
donc le 8 novembre,
qui, je l'ai appris hier,
correspond au jour où Aaron aurait eu 30 ans,
le 8 novembre,
nous célébrerons 218 élus à la Chambre des représentants
et 60 sénateurs élus
au Sénat des Etats-Unis
qui se sont engagés dans cette idée
de réforme fondamentale.
Hier, nous avons parlé de vœux.
Voici le mien.
Le 1er mai.
Puissent les idéals d'un garçon
unir une nation derrière une idée cruciale,
que nous sommes un peuple,
que nous sommes le peuple à qui l'on a promis un gouvernement,
un gouvernement qui promettait
de dépendre sur le peuple seul, juste le peuple,
lequel, comme nous l'a dit Madison,
ne s'agissait pas davantage des riches que des pauvres.
Le 1er mai.
Puissiez-vous rejoindre ce mouvement
non pas parce que vous êtes politiciens,
non pas parce que vous êtes experts,
ou que c'est votre domaine,
mais parce que si vous existez,
vous êtes citoyens.
C'est ce qu'Aaron m'a demandé.
Maintenant je vous le demande.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)